[Applause]
it's kind of nice huh yeah you know
thanks so much for coming she's right
it was our guy loves you by the way he
thinks no me I have a chance now you
were you know it's you know what some
it's really nice I was so glad you could
do the show I don't think people well
people don't know this but you were in
the audience at my audition yeah it was
neat seen that tape yeah so you were at
that it was so nice we were like yeah
don't mock our real moment yeah it was
no but that was I mean obviously a big
night in my life but we of course were
like best friends at the time and you
you came and you sat in the audition sat
through the whole thing and told me you
can do it yeah I looked all droopy and
what was I why didn't you the least you
could have done is say buy a real jacket
don't don't don't use the Sears jacket
from your trunk of your car remember
we're trying to make it not a big deal
yeah right like it wasn't and you at the
time we're going through a lot yeah I
was thanks for bringing it by a gun
fired from Frasier wait what no I just
meant in your you know you had a
birthday recently me you were I remember
a time you were gonna do Frasier and it
didn't work out the pilot you were
really upset and I said something
betters gonna remember I said something
that is gonna come along see yeah yeah I
got to go to the late-night thing but I
said something better is gonna come
along and then it did yeah yeah you were
right I was just being nice right
exactly
all this story should be about me but
you were really funny
no please now please straight like this
yeah I learned to sit upright it took me
seven years
and that was the whole key yeah right
exactly I I wanted to mention something
one thing that a lot of people don't
know about you that I know because we
were friends for so long is your special
dessert that you whip up for your good
friends that I want to share with people
a I used to live like three blocks away
from Lisa this is back in the early days
were struggling Lisa always used to call
me up and say I'm making my special
dessert come on over and have some her
special dessert
that's that's so depresses maybe anyway
here it was yeah so I'd come over and
her special dessert was you would buy a
big bag of mms pour him on a tray put
him in the microwave and melt it into
goo and then yeah it was good
yeah you just melted into goo and you'd
say it's an old family recipe the
microwave is like 15 years old how can
it be an old family recipe it originated
in the toaster oven which goes back to
the 15th century
very nice yeah I understand you're
getting a little you've been irritated
lately with the tabloids is that true
well a little bit not you know not a
huge amount but um you know they just
they make things up and it's I mean I
don't have it as bad as other people do
so that's okay but you know they just
make you know they make things up about
you too
no I have had I've been in the tabloids
only twice I am and both of my made-up
stories were so lame twice I've been in
one was Conan O'Brien has really high
cholesterol and they got they just cut
out around my head you know they just
cut out your head so your heads just
floating and they got a picture like
that and B the other story was they got
a picture of me just like looking kind
of confused or something and they said
Conan's pal says he doesn't wash his
hands after using the bathroom
yeah so thanks Andy I you know there's
only so much that I I just always
thought like I want a better story than
that I want caught in caught in love
nest with Jerry Ryan or something I
never had make it something good if
you're just gonna plumb make it up
they said Kourtney and I were is seen it
at Pea in the pod maternity shop you
know but we weren't we weren't yeah but
well who cares that's not like a bad one
you're not let you know what I mean who
cares I know but why do they go to the
trouble to just you know what can we do
what do they think that's gonna be
really great I believe a tabloid came
out and they just made up things that
weren't even that interesting
you know like Lisa Kudrow prefers
broccoli over carrots exclamation point
confused looking picture of you
broccoli next to you and life is good
and everything's fine yeah everything's
really good I I see you all the time so
I know your husband Michelle of course
his family's from from France and I'm
curious do they get the show do they get
friends over there yeah it's really big
and it's really really big in France
it's big in France yeah so you know now
most of his relatives know who I am
mm-hm and some of them just know and
then this was the only thing I didn't
know how to take this some of them have
visited and then they left they called
it Michelle and so we had a really nice
time thank you and you know what your
wife got prettier maybe that that's a
nice thing they don't they weren't
saying you were a hideous ghoul before
that's what I hear
Oh see well that's I hear she was
everything before and now thank God for
you well how do they show it in in
France do they do they use is it
subtitle though they dub it they debit
well there's a cable they show subtitles
that's the cool one right and then you
know like on the network TV it's don't I
would I think would be so weird to see
yourself Doug I've never seen that but
when you watch friends dubbed is it like
well hello Phoebe how are you I am fine
Monica is good you see is it like that
is it I haven't really watched it I have
to be honest I've only heard about it
you've never met any of the people that
have done me the voices or anything like
that
no but I've heard I mean there's one
I've heard in Czechoslovakia there's one
guy
one guy just does the voices of everyone
on the show at first I thought it was
one guy doing all the voices and I found
out he just narrates there right so it's
me talking like Oh Chandler you're so
floopy or you know whatever I would say
this what is he translating to you know
the Czechoslovakian people Oh Chandler
you're so I don't know what he's doing
Phoebe finds Chandler floopy yeah yeah
yeah now she's leaving the room and
acting confused very strange I'm just
gonna be quiet yeah yeah it's not making
people yell I'm sorry
well we gotta go friends is of course
like I have to mention this it's so
funny I better tell people when friends
is on Thursdays at 8 o'clock helped that
fledgling show it's on NBC Lisa thanks
so much for coming so nice to have you
Lisa Kudrow everybody we'll take a break
we'll be right back